I'm here with dr. Romano Marvy hello and
what are we going to talk about we're
talking about arthritis today our right
is something that I've heard a lot about
but what exactly does it mean
so arthritis I think in Greek ours is
ours are throwed joint and itis is
inflammation I see it if you literally
interpret it means joint so just having
joint pain doesn't necessarily mean you
have arthritis you have to have some
underlying and some inflammation I see
and is it just one disease
oh no there are about a hundred
different types of arthritis and since
this depends on what is causing that
inflammation we can categorize them in
many many many different ways so the
most common arthritis that most people
know about and think about is
osteoarthritis it's more of a deed we
call it degenerative arthritis and the
other next common most common is
rheumatoid arthritis and then there's
about you know like a hundred other
types of arthritis and I'll just briefly
mention you know so arthritis or
inflammation could be due to an
infection so maybe that's septic
arthritis it could you chew crystals or
a gout people have heard of that and
multiple other other things I see so
just so you're aware of that I see we're
going to focus on the most common ones
which is osteoarthritis which is about
osteoarthritis is about 10% of
population but when you really look at
it about 30% of women after the age of
60 will have osteoarthritis well and
about 20% of men and some in one joint
at least I see as opposed to rheumatoid
arthritis which is considered more of an
inflammatory type of arthritis because
it is it has a lot more inflammation
swelling warmth so when we talk about
inflammation those are the symptoms are
gonna be you're gonna in addition to
having pain you're gonna have swelling
you're gonna have warmth you're gonna
have stiffness you may or may not have
redness depending
how severe the inflammation is okay so
that high-level what what are the what
are the different symptoms between the
two yeah so oh not only are different
joints affected in osteoarthritis versus
rheumatoid arthritis
most people who have osteoarthritis will
complain of having a complaint of pain
usually in the evenings
they'll have pain after they've done a
pretty strenuous you know some activity
or they've overused that joint they're
gonna have more pain they complain of
stiffness mostly but stiffness is
lasting only for about five minutes in
the morning so when they wake up they
loosen up but then you know thirty
minutes maximum is you know five or
thirty minutes is when you feel that
stiffness and it starts getting better
as you start moving around as opposed to
in rheumatoid arthritis where most of
the pain and stiffness is happening
early in the morning when they wake up
oh my god they feel you know it takes
them an hour to two hours to start
moving around and and feeling loose
again so you're saying I'm surprised
usually the pains of the evening they
might have at most five to thirty
minutes of just kind of a little bit of
stiffness in the rheumatoid arthritis if
that's where their their pain is yeah
mornings is worse of course you know
both of these diseases you can have pain
all throughout the day but generally
it's worse in the morning for rheumatoid
arthritis patients and it improves as
the day goes on it also improves with
activity so the more active and
rheumatoid patient is the less their
symptoms are bothering them if they're
sitting for too long they're gonna feel
like things just are hurting more and
officers right it's improves with
activity as well osteo artis is opposite
so it's more active they are the more in
hurts because this overuse related it's
more you use the joint the more the pain
will be so that's just kind of basic you
know ways you can classify some of the
symptoms and that's how we try to tease
what could be the cause of the symptoms
the other thing way that osteoarthritis
and rheumatoid arthritis are different
is that in osteoarthritis it's so mostly
the joints affected are the
weight-bearing joints so your spine so
it could be neck it could be lumber
lumbar spine lower back spine
hips and knees spine hips knees and then
your hands so certain some joints of the
hand are effective in rheumatoid
arthritis
since it's not necessarily
weight-bearing you can have arthritis
mostly in hands wrists elbows shoulders
feet knees as well and hips as well but
you know in Ostia Arthur is very large
sweet bearing joints and that's
important to know is hands and both but
but hands also in in osteoarthritis
there are certain joints of the hand
that are affected inventory there's
other hands are affected so that also
other things we want to talk about I
didn't mention the incidence of
rheumatoid arthritis so it's about one
percent of the population it's much more
common in women than men it's usually in
women in their 40s and 60s will develop
rheumatoid arthritis but again people
fall outside of that as well
osteoarthritis is a disease of older age
so older you get the more likely you
will get it but not all old people will
have osteoarthritis so there is a
genetic predisposition for it as well
there's also if you are obese you have a
higher risk of developing osteoarthritis
because your weight-bearing joints are
affected and if you've had some injury
to the joint so in the past if you had
you know you played soccer and you
pulled a ligament in your knee then in
the future instability of the joint and
can cause more likely tab lost your
arthritis in the future so and other
things are overused so people who do
some repetitive activities for a long
long time could potentially cause some
injury to that joint that's micro
injuries and and back in later develop
into osteoarthritis what about again
it's women women genetics oh definitely
feel like is common to both common to
both and
beyond that I mean we don't know really
know the cause and we don't really
there's no other real way to project
multi develop rheumatoid arthritis and
rheumatoid arthritis
you do have since then it's an
autoimmune disease your immune system is
acting inappropriately and it's causing
inflammation of your in your own joints
and it's not an infection or anything
like that we don't think so far so
because your immune system is acting
inappropriate apparently there are some
blood markers in the blood and you're in
your blood if you have rheumatoid
arthritis such as rheumatoid factor and
people talk about and other tests I can
that can indicate that you have a high
risk for having it or you may have it I
see so let's talk a little bit about
what is actually going on in
osteoarthritis rheumatoid arthritis and
you can look at this photo here and I
can show you what what different things
here are so this is an example of a
joint and you see there are two bones
coming together to make and the lining
right around that bone and the gray or
brown color is that's the thickness it's
the cartilage this entire area so
cartilage is basically a spongy material
that services a shock absorber for your
joint and lining the cartilage is in
blue you see that there are some fluid
and so that the fluid is also going to
help with the shock absorbing and
helping have a nice gliding motion when
you are moving that joint right the
fluid is lined by a synovial lining or
membranes no fluid lined by membrane
where there cells and these cells are
immune cells and for some reason in
rheumatoid arthritis those cells
replicate and can get caused a local
inflammation the membrane just gets
thicker thicker and because there's so
much other there recruiting other cells
and more
you know blood flow that causes
destruction of the surrounding
structures so you can get destruction of
the bones right there and they can make
holes in the bones call it we call them
erosions they can also cause destruction
of the surrounding ligaments of the
cartilage and that causes you to get
pain causes deformities of the joint and
causes instability of the joints so the
joint can't function that's in
rheumatoid arthritis and osteoarthritis
we don't think that the synovial
membrane is that active again there is
some level of inflammation going on
there but most of it is related to the
cartilage lining getting getting micro
injury and that overtime can get
breakdown and eventually just disappear
altogether cartilage lining and also
when you develop bone hitting bone
because the cartilage is now gone you
can imagine that's quite painful but
also because bone hits bone there's also
other things that are dysregulated and
you end up getting more bone formation
so they have extra bone just keeps
growing and causes starts hitting other
area other structures around and causes
pain and deformity and usually joints
get bigger oh wow
so if I were to summer this is very
helpful if I were to summarize it
arthritis is not just one disease it's
kind of a class of symptoms around joint
inflammation exactly and as you
mentioned there's hundreds of types of
it
the most typical are osteoarthritis and
rheumatoid Ostrow is very difficult ten
percent of the population that's huge
rheumatoid is one percent so still a
significant number of people but it's
not as frequent as osteo and from what
I'm hearing it sounds like because you
know osteoarthritis is weight-bearing
joints it's you get it from injury to
joint sore from overuse obviously
genetics is a part of it but it seems
like it's much more of a I guess for
lack of a better word it's much more of
a mechanical kind of a mechanically
induced disease we don't know for sure
mechanical obesity is a risk factor
while rheumatoid arthritis a lot of
inflammation a lot of inflammation it's
something much more your immune system
is responding in some in some way
exactly very cool there you have it
thank you